the story of Michael Jordan has been
told and retold but the story of his
signature shoe not so much let's unbox
the ending of the movie adaptation of
this famous sneaker Saga warning
spoilers for air just ahead
when we meet Sonny Vaquero Nike's
Intrepid basketball Scout he's presented
as a gambler a man who uses his
knowledge of basketball to win money to
pour into yet another bet but the
chances he takes are always rooted in
his instinctive grasp of the game in air
Sunny's journey is another Gambit as he
uses his sense of the game's cultural
landscape to make a giant bet on Michael
Jordan
I'm willing to bet my career on Michael
Jordan oh come on man by the end of the
film we know that Sonny's gamble has
paid off he lands the Jordan deal gets
Nike CEO Phil Knight to agree to give
the Jordan family a revenue share on
every shoe sold
he also wins Vindication having
advocated for what everyone else at Nike
thought was a crazy idea he saw Jordan
as the great player and icon that he
would become even if no one seemed to
believe him but himself and Jordan's
mother Dolores this time though Sunny
doesn't just throw the payoff into the
next gamble instead he takes the lessons
he learns from the Jordan deal and pours
them into advocacy for still more
players eventually becoming a crusader
for the rights of college athletes Sunny
has clearly grown even if he remains a
gambler at heart
as air begins fill night is a
comfortable confident CEO who's built
Nike into a major player in the sneaker
Market even if the company doesn't quite
compete with Converse or Adidas Nike is
a running shoe company Phil is a runner
and these things all sit well with him
they feel like the reliable standard of
business at a time when the company is
facing losses which makes him very risk
adverse when Sunny suggests betting a
huge chunk of his basketball budget of
one player
I don't know
seriously but as Sunny points out to
Phil more than once Nike was built on
risk and Phil's willingness to make
gutsy choices on his way to the top it's
only by remembering that feeling through
the rules he's enshrined on his office
wall that Phil can start to grow and
evolve Nike once again when he focuses
on his breathing then makes the call to
allow Jordan to get a revenue share on
his signature shoe it's a sign that he's
seen the truth of what the path forward
should be it may seem like a nonchalant
decision but it's actually a paradigm
shift for Nike's zen master
though Michael Jordan is the focus of
every other character in air he doesn't
get much screen time at all instead the
avatar for the Jordan family is
Michael's mother Dolores who runs the
family from her home in Wilmington and
sees sunny as an Earnest deal maker who
could truly do something special for her
son but Dolores Jordan is not just a
Savvy deal maker who understands how her
son thinks and feels in a movie full of
strategists she proves to be the
greatest long-term thinker it's Dolores
who Advocates not just for Michael to
get a lucrative shoe deal and a new car
but for Michael to work with a company
that's going to elevate him to the level
she feels he deserves it's Dolores who
tells Sunny what Michael will do once he
makes it to the NBA and it's Dolores who
realizes that Michael has the potential
to be more than just a famous athlete
she advocates for him through the
Revolutionary idea of Revenue sharing
which brought Untold Fortune to the
Jordan family Dolores who went on to run
charities in her family's name saw
Michael's rise as something that could
lift other black families alongside her
own and through her Advocacy she made
that possible
Rob Strasser Nike's long-suffering
basketball marketing executive spends
much of air trying to manage everyone's
expectations he enters the movie
intending to pursue multiple
middle-of-the-road incoming NBA players
trying to get the most bang out of his
division's meager budget when Sonny
comes to him with the idea of pursuing a
single athlete he bulks insisting that
it's the kind of decision that could
lead to all the Nike basketball
employees losing their jobs look if
anybody back there asks where I am just
tell him I'm sick you got it sick in the
head but there's more to this Than Pride
for Rob as he explains to Sunny he's a
divorced man who only gets to see his
daughter once a week and his ability to
give her free shoes and prove his worth
as a guy who works at Nike is a
Cornerstone of that relationship if he
loses his job he won't just lose income
and purpose but what he perceives as the
best way to forge a stronger bond in his
fractured family when the deal Works
Rob's trust in Sunny is validated but so
is the strong strength of his
convictions it's a moment of Triumph
that hits Rob on several levels which
makes it more powerful
early in air as Sunny is pleading with
Phil for more resources to devote to the
basketball Division Phil begins to
expound on why he likes the company the
way it is before the Jordan deal changes
everything they sell running shoes Phil
argues which are shoes that people wear
while they're running but also while
they're doing errands or going to work
or just hanging around the house it's a
sound business model and while it's not
built on cultural relevance it is built
on serving a very solid need when it
comes to basketball shoes Phil estimates
the market cap on the product is perhaps
a million units spread across all
companies because he just doesn't see
people buying basketball shoes to wear
out in the world signing Jordan and
building not just one shoe but an entire
line around the young star changes that
forever Adidas were the cool shoes when
the film began but with Jordan at Nike
that began to shift and soon Nike was at
the center not just of basketball but
pop culture the company changed in a
matter of years and it would never be
the same again
though Michael Jordan is a character in
air and appears on screen in certain
pivotal scenes we never see the young
Stars face except an archival footage
that showcases the real Michael Jordan
according to director Ben Affleck in an
interview with The Hollywood Reporter
this was a deliberate choice because he
knew the audience would project their
own version of Michael Jordan onto the
character no matter how he was portrayed
despite Jordan's relative absence from
the story air is all about Jordan and
the recognition of his Legend even from
an early age in one pivotal scene Sunny
re-watches a single play from Jordan's
College days over and over he realizes
that the play was always designed for
the 18 year old athlete to execute and
despite the pressure Jordan was poised
to win under any circumstances it's not
just proof of talent or even a cool head
under pressure for sunny and eventually
for Nike it's proof of his absolute
greatness which would go on to transcend
basketball and make him an
internationally known figure by the end
of the film air has made the case and
it's done despite barely showing Michael
on screen
in the final meeting that helps Nike
secure the deal with Michael Jordan
Executives set out to show a video that
will hopefully Dazzle their prospective
signee but Sunny interrupts it instead
of showing a highlight reel of Jordan
himself and how he could work at Nike
Sunny launches into an extended
monologue about Jordan as a player and
his future as a star as Sonny tells
Jordan that he's about to experience the
highest highs of any athlete ever as
well as the lowest lows we see a montage
of all of those highs and lows playing
out the film shows us Jordan's NBA
Heights his tab white headlines the
death of his father and even his
short-lived baseball career before his
NBA comeback we see all of that while
Sunny talks laying out not just
Michael's potential but his path as a
singular figure in American Sports
it's a vital moment in the film because
it underscores that we the audience
already know Michael Jordan's future
we've known it from the beginning the
film therefore is not just about a shoe
deal it's about a consequential moment
that took shape at a key point in time
and changed the world into monsterable
ways that we can still see
the NBA had Stars before Michael Jordan
of course but air points out that
through his early merchandising moves
Jordan had the potential to become a
bigger star than anyone before him and
in the process change the face of the
NBA Forever by building a line centered
on Jordan complete with commercials and
even a logo that reflected his
high-flying likeness Nike put a
spotlight on an NBA star in ways no
other shoe company ever had he became
the centerpiece of an entire cultural
moment which he was able to back up with
major achievements on the basketball
court because of that the popularity of
the NBA Rose but something else also
happened the nature of Jordan's deal and
the revenue stream it created meant that
future Superstars could follow in his
footsteps making the NBA a league of
players more than a league of teams
before setting out to make error Ben
Affleck reached out to Michael Jordan
himself to ask for guidance it was
important to Affleck he told The
Hollywood Reporter that the film be
something that Jordan wouldn't object to
and he wanted the Legends advice on how
to proceed according to Affleck Jordan
emphasized the importance of athlete
relations representative Howard white in
making the deal at Nike giving Chris
Tucker more leeway to emphasize the
character in the film they don't matter
about what Phil is thinking or anybody's
thinking
all that matters is how much do you
believe
most importantly Jordan emphasized just
how crucial his mother was in the
process and even requested that Viola
Davis be the one to play her at the time
Dolores was not a major player in the
script which left Affleck with an
important decision the director decided
to reframe The Narrative making air much
more about the Jordan family and Dolores
in particular securing Davis for the
role as Jordan requested it was a
decision that changed the entire shape
of the narrative particularly the ending
as Dolores becomes the one who advocates
for her sons unprecedented deal without
that input from Jordan Air would not
have been the same movie it turned out
to be
foreign